a todos obrigado para aqui com este
evento a eu queria fazer uma pergunta e
cria conciliação soul music com as mãos
do sr pó concordam
sim quem de vocês sabe intrinsecamente
que ser grato traz felicidade
[Música]
isso porque quando nós vivemos uma vida
grata chegamos ao final do dia que vemos
no nosso diário a eu gostei disso eu
gostei daquilo sentindo algo ocorrer
dentro de nós que nos leva a uma noção
do fluence dá certo
existe aquela empatia com o outro e com
nós próprios que sabemos que fizemos
algo que é bom e que nos traz algo mais
quando estamos assim no travesseiro e
pensar no jockey
pois foi um dia que eu conseguir
realizar algo certo e no estado em que
vocês estão por exemplo do trabalho do
família de desenvolvimento profissional
esse estado gratidão consegue nos
transportar até os nossos objetivos e eu
criamos dizer nunca me faltou carinho da
minha história em conjunto também com
uma pesquisa que houve há uns tempos
atrás que é do ort e mexe eu não sei se
vocês conhecem mas eu pesquisou várias
coisas sobre gratidão ea 12 uma das
coisas que acontecia era que o nível de
felicidade das suas mais gratas
aumentava eo nível de corrupção diminui
a ou seja desde que nós sabemos que
somos gratos conseguimos nossos
objetivos indicamos banho
e até termos provas científicas
comprovam isso
então porque muitas vezes nós estamos
top 15
muitas vezes nós sentimos um vazio em
crise mas faltava um pouquinho certo
então na minha história é eu dei um
colégio católico muito tradicional e
depois fui para formular católica
esperava católica portuguesa poderá
consumir antes
então meu objetivo era muito perigoso e
eu vou ser trocada contencioso
administrativo cintífica mento
contencioso administrativo que tem a ver
com empresas do estado etc
e eu vou casar eu vou ter filhos e vou
ter uma casa eu vou ter um caso eo ronco
formar em se tiver sorte um dia um ovo
pacificamente ea maioria de nós tem um
carinho dessas perspectivas de vida
quando eu cheguei à faculdade e conheci
o joão estava neste caminho que por para
muitas pessoas até conhecer vai
insistindo
eu descobri que tanto eu como não
tínhamos um vasinho faltava são paulo eu
queria sempre mais
então por cinco anos na faculdade
católica cadeirantes se de enviar pros
meus pais eles é o pai e mãe eu vou ser
a maquiadora e eu não quero nada deste
ano quer teorias e não quero
funcionalidade eu quero criar eu quero
ser criativa e então já quando tinha 13
anos de idade hospital maquiagem mas
nunca achei que em portugal vai ser uma
profissão mas mesmo assim avançam em e
conseguir constituir a minha casa ainda
trabalhava bicavam cinco horas por dia
ver vídeos no youtube
fui fazer curso em londres ex há sempre
uma vida muito privilégio uma vida muito
muito grande minha se antes e não
consegue fazer os meus trabalhos de
maquiagem isso por acaso até foi feito
em 11 anos e chega um ponto em que
conseguir será o maquiador oficial da
bola deixou portugal na área da
maquiagem isso é considerado um bom
carro mas algo me dizia que a vida
então o que eu queria fazer foi já
é um cargo em portugal o problema e vou
avançar na minha vida vou pesquisar
novos idéias criar em artes e como tinha
sido o maquiador oficial do vale
shopping eu disse eu vou estar lá e vou
ter um trabalho lá e não vai ser fácil
mas eu vou conseguir
eu cheguei a londres e meu mundo desabou
um outro privilégio que eu tenha sempre
um país na minha cabeça que eu tenho um
carro para guiar que eu tinha tudo se no
imaginário do conforto
eu achei um bônus fiquei sem nada nada a
ponto de quando eu cheguei há alguns
anos era parte do natal com suada e não
tinha 50 pés no meu bolso para por
açúcar nas baladas
eu comecei a caminhar uma hora em se
envolve nesse janeiro até um trabalho
que eu estava porque não conseguia pagar
para tocar eu comecei a olhar pra mim e
disse tu és porque é porque todos os
bens materiais e toda aquela
sensibilidade que eu ia na vida por si
eu comecei a trabalhar embaixo com seis
tribunais e tenta colar às quatro e meia
da manhã de quarta não vou comparar com
algum ao mundo a síria ou a índia
concentra em que as pessoas sofrem muito
mais no meu mundo eu tinha essa imagem
que estava muito triste estava acusada
que então o que aconteceu eu a bater no
fundo do poço eu conseguia perceber
alguma coisa na minha vida é que por
muito que eu tivesse uma casa ainda duas
carreiras que tivesse entrado com os
direitos maquiagem e 69 sempre alguma
coisa então aqui eu começo a ter um
caminho mais de dinheiro um caminho mais
sucesso e eu começar a agradecer todas
as coisas pequeninas que eu tenho na
minha vida eu comecei dizendo por aí
o objetivo da minha vida não é o seu
grande nem estou grávida que o objetivo
é observar todas as coisinhas que está
em todos os corações que toca todas as
pessoas compreendam paulo ii quando
estivesse no céu
eu tenho vou fazer a minha empresa fazer
a vontade é uma empresa com o que foi
uma empresa ecológica do que não ter
nada não fez muito pouco não fez eu
quando pensava em construir a arrancar
que avançar na minha vida eu pensava eu
quero ter lucro mas eu quero ter lucro
para um projecto que o lucro pra ajudar
alguém
eu quero ter um carro pra que o cliente
fique contente porque o que eu tenho
então mais mais mais que eu queria aqui
sem rendimentos - passei em uma cama
você dormir no chão
você tinha próximos vizinhos extra
sempre nada em troca
você fazer a montaria fiz nunca eram
atrozes que a chuva a unidade da light
nem vi aqui é uma comunidade muito pobre
e passa muitas dificuldades e eu comecei
a ver meu reflexo empatia é com trazia
verdadeira sociedade e ir lentamente
constrói a sua rede
o conselho que eu vos dou tendo em conta
é que o que eu aprendi e aquilo que eu
fiz na minha carreira e na minha
profissão e na minha vida pessoal foi
tiro em um processo em que comecem a
apreciar as pequenas coisinhas da vossa
vida e aí vocês vão com saque da sua
rede passará no spoiler linha verde o
autor não precisa deste ano é preciso
mais aqui eu só preciso ter empatia e
ajudar alguém
eu não sou dizia passar em forma eu não
estou a dizer não tirem as vossas bonés
tições mas quando tiverem intensa na
partilha pensa em dar ao próximo e aí
essa gratidão vai começar agora
muito obrigado a todos por estarem aqui
então é uma experiência foi muito
parecida com a rita eu tinha um monte de
privilégios casa paga carro f150 gastar
o dinheirinho que fosse meu
mas eu também não era feliz em ver
alguma coisa que estava constantemente a
falta em mim então nós quando estamos em
londres na última casa não sabiam que
ser moída e disney fox ou continuamos a
viver o mesmo hostil vida e continuar
vivendo uma casa e fazer as mesmas
coisas que fazíamos antes ou realizar um
sonho já tínhamos a lesão antes quero
viver dentro de uma carrinha uma coisa
assim muito estranha e tem uns alguns
momentos de sá quando conseguir comprá
lo e converteu e transformar tudo se
evitava mas teve uma paixão muito grande
por trás
então conseguimos fazer o compramos a
nossa primeira linha e simples tornando
as obras construímos a nossa primeira
casa fizemos projetos e os guarda costas
que já era um espaço completamente
brasil e tínhamos toda a criatividade
para fazer e eu criamos então mandamos
as mãos à obra e simples e muito do
assunto os temos nossos passos e
começarmos a apreciar o facto de terem
de pequenas coisas à nossa volta disse
nós deixamos dormir no quarto numa cama
e dormir no chão nos sentimos mais
confortáveis mais próximos um do outro
até que foi uma coisa incrível ter essa
mudança no estilo de vida
foi incrível eu poder ter prendido
construir coisas que não sabia fazer
nada estava muito para fazer mas não
tinha noção nenhuma quando consegui
fazer o que pesquisei na internet muitos
vídeos e municípios o que eu poderia
fazer para alcançar a minha felicidade
disse uma coisa que ao ter essa
experiência ao passar de muito dinheiro
para literalmente povos seu conceito
alguma rita é ter gratidão por tudo que
era dado o apoio das pessoas que estavam
à minha volta a paciência que não come
com a vontade queriam partilhar as suas
próprias experiências através disso
conhecemos pessoas magníficas todas as
idades de todas as raças foram mesmo
apaixonante para nós viajamos para a
cites incríveis nova casa que parece
muito mas limitaram os presentes
incríveis fomos àguas em bares e
restaurantes parques nacionais no sul da
inglaterra é fantástico é uma coisa que
só mesmo vivendo aquela para escrever
mesmo assim nós precisamos logo mais na
nossa vida
então quando ela criou a rádio
com sentido de fazer caridade com as
pessoas não porque temos algo em troca
não o lucro principal objetivo final da
empresa mas para fazer as pessoas rir
claro que temos dinheiro para sobreviver
contra agentes já assim criamos algo
mais que fizesse a nossa vida
então criamos um projeto chamado pink
hawks hospital racks é um projeto que
nós dois somos feministas sou
completamente a favor dos direitos entre
homens e mulheres e achamos que havia
uma grande disparidade dos refugiados e
os 60 países viverem aqui então seguinte
precisamos criar imagens para mostrar
aos europeus como é que uma mulher
vivendo é que ensina refugiada consegue
fazer as mesmas coisas comemorou
perfazem as condições completamente
diferentes já que não vamos concessão de
imaginar que são os outros os refugiados
tom sofrer tal imaginamos que são os
europeus criando ans que estão aqui
precisam da nossa ajuda
então continuamos com esse projeto mas
nos sentimos questões muito importantes
para nós
será que estou grato por aquilo que já
tem
será que eu preciso do que tem sou capaz
de dalva mim foi uma experiência mesmo
incrível e construirmos mais enquanto
pessoas que tínhamos imensos não porque
o deus ter do edifício enviados fazer
que o poderemos ter um difícil
espiritual e aproveitamos contar uma
história muito engraçada sobre gratidão
no ano passado estávamos a chegar ao
antes depois farías em portugal e à
nossa quem estava preso não se iria
fechar desta noite não havia outras aos
consequentemente não tinha um sítio para
dormir
ligamos para alguns amigos não tínhamos
um homem que forma passada noite motivos
logísticos não conseguiu ajudar o abrigo
naquela noite
então tivemos que dormir na rua naquele
momento estava completamente estressado
imaginar mas porque é que isto acontece
nem porque a vida é tomar porque tinha
de ser eu já vi uma criança e tenta um
pouco e agora vou ter menos ainda e no
dia seguinte quando voltei consegui
minha carrinha eu comecei a pensar e
espera aí eu tenho uma filhinha eu tenho
uma noite na rua foi uma coisa
estressante mas ao mesmo tempo em que
levamos e agora vou poder continuar a
apreciar e viajar
vitor fez uma pergunta que foi
vocês podem ser feliz sendo grátis
minha receita uma minha sugestão é
bastante simples
nem tudo que vocês têm não é no sentido
literal da em todos os vossos vencer e
viver na rua
após um caso complicado mas nem a voz
unida tem as nossas roupas a história de
um falso foi o vosso tempo ouvir alguém
e garante os pneuzinhos princípio ao que
em troca
vou ter um conhecimento entre ou
daquelas pessoas que vão enriquecer
muito mais esclarecimento só será de
entre 90 e desejam votar
[Aplausos]